- - Ces images inédites obtenues
papar l'émission "Enquête" ont é
cacaptées il y a quelques mois
àà l'école Polytechnique
dede Montréal. On a testé
lala résistance de cinq suspents
dudu pont Pierre-Laporte à Québc
ququi ont été retiré au cours
dedes deux dernières années,
unune demande du ministère
dedes Transports. Au fur et
àà mesure que la charge augment,
onon peut entendre des fils
d'd'acier qui cassent...
(b(bruit de rupture)
..... jusqu'à la rupture du câb.
PlPlusieurs câbles testés
enen laboratoire avaient perdu
plplus de la moitié
dede leur résistance d'origine,
jujusqu'à 57 %. Le pire résultat
obobtenu depuis qu'on a commencé
ceces tests en 2015.
LeLes 160 suspentes du pont
PiPierre-Laporte sont composées
dede deux câbles verticaux
chchacune. Elles servent
àà retenir le tablier du pont.
LeLes câbles sont tellement
didifficiles à inspecter que
c'c'est impossible de connaître
leleur état réel sans les enlev.
MaMais les récents tests et
leles dernières inspections
lele confirment, ces câbles sont
dede plus en plus rouillés.
- - Je dirais qu'il est minuit
momoins une. Plus il y a
dede corrosion, plus ça va
acaccélérer le phénomène. Donc,
àà un moment donné, on perd
unun peu de contrôle.
- - Un ingénieur bien au fait
dede la situation s'inquiète.
- - Visiblement, le message
nene se rend pas parce que
sisi le message se rendait,
onon n'en serait pas là.
- - Nous avons eu quelques
rerencontres, mais il a refusé
totoute entrevue à la caméra.
NoNous avons accepté de protéger
soson identité parce qu'il crait
dede sububir des représailles.
- - Le problème, c'est que
leles choses avancent pas.
IlIl y a rien qui est prévu ence
popour le remplacement complet
dedes suspentes à court terme.
- - Certains câbles du pont
PiPierre-Laporte sont
enen si mauvais état qu'ils
popourraient céder à tout moment
seselon nos informations.
CaCamions lourds, vents et
trtremblements de terre peuvent
afaffecter les suspentes déjà
afaffaiblies par la corrosion.
- - Imaginez une suspente
ququi mesure plusieurs dizaines
dede mètres qui cède, puis qui
totombe sur des voitures en bas.
- - Sans compter le risque
dede rupture en cascade.
- - Si on avait le malheur
ququ'il y ait deux ou trois
sususpentes côte à côte qui
avavaient perdu la moitié
dede leur résistance, on pourrat
avavoir cet effet domino.
- - Et visiblement, notre lancer
d'd'alerte n'est pas le seul
àà s'inquiéter. "Enquête" a mis
lala main sur un récent rapport
sisigné par deux ingénieurs
dudu ministère des Transports.
IlIls écrivent :
"I"Il faut absolument éviter
lala rupture d'une ou de plusies
sususpentes, avec comme finalité
pepeu probable, mais potentiell,
unune catastrophique rupture
enen cascade pouvant ultimement
cacauser l'effondrement
dede l'ouvrage."
InInvité à commenter
nonos révélations, le ministère
dedes Transports nous a offert
unune entrevue avec celui
ququi coordonne et planifie
leles travaux du pont Pierre-
LaLaporte.
CHCHRISTIAN MERCIER, ingénieur,
ststruct. majeurs, Transports Qc
- - Je suis pas au courant
dede ce rapport-là
mamalheureusement.
- - Vous êtes pas au courant?
VoVous êtes responsable
dudu pont Laporte, puis il y a
dedes ingénieurs du ministère
ququi ont fait un rapport
dede plus de 100 pages
susur le système de suspension.
- - Bien, on savait qu'il y avat
unun rapport global sur la gestn
dede l'ouvrage qui s'en venait,
mamais...
- - Sur le système de suspensio.
- - Mais on savait pas
ququ'il y avait urgence
enen à la demeure comme vous
lele dites. Ça, j'étais pas
auau courant.
- - Le rapport a été déposé
lele 21 avril à des gestionnairs
etet des hauts fonctionnaires
dudu ministère. Les auteurs
rerecommandent le remplacement
cocomplet des suspentes.
"L"Le plus tôt sera le mieux.
CeCertaines doivent l'être
àà court terme pour éviter
leles remplacements en urgence u
dedes impacts importants au nivu
dede l'exploitation du pont."
ChChristian Mercier et son équie
s's'appuient sur l'expertise
d'd'une firme américaine qui
mmène des tests supplémentaires
susur les suspentes.
- - Bien, les tests de résistane
àà Polytechnique, ça a été fouri
àà notre expert. Moi, je peux ps
titirer de conclusions. Je suis
papas un expert en pont suspend.
OnOn va avoir des recommandatios
dadans les prochaines semaines.
OnOn suit les recommandations
ququ'on reçoit. On n'a pas eu
dede recommandations qu'il fallt
reremplacer les suspentes
àà très court terme. Nos experts
s's'entendent pour dire que
popour l'instant, la situation
esest stable, est sous contrôle.
- - Dans un monde idéal,
onon serait même déjà en travau.
AiAilleurs dans le monde,
ddès qu'on découvre une suspente
enendommagée, on va commencer
reremplacement de toutes
leles suspentes.
- - Plusieurs ponts suspendus
àà travers le monde ont subi
unun premier remplacement complt
dede suspentes avant leur 50 an.
LeLe pont Pierre-Laporte, lui,
a a 52 ans. Jusqu'à maintenant,
onon change les suspentes
lolorsqu'une inspection visuelle
enen démontre l'urgence.
SeSeulement 15 ont été remplacés
àà ce jour.
- - Si on agit pas à temps,
ilil pourrait être trop tard!
TrTrop tard ne veut pas
nénécessairement dire que
lele pont se ramasserait
dadans le fond du fleuve,
mamais on peut pas se permettre
dede le fermer plusieurs semain.
CeCe serait impensable!
- - Parce que selon plusieurs
exexperts, la rupture d'une seue
sususpente forcerait la fermetue
dudu pont, le temps d'inspecter
totoute la structure.
CeCe qui pourrait prendre
plplusieurs jours ou même
dedes semaines. Et les impacts
seseraient majeurs.
PlPlus de 125 000 véhicules
frfranchissent le pont
PiPierre-Laporte chaque jour.
C'C'est le seul lien permettant
auaux camions lourds traverser
lele fleuve à l'est
dede Trois-Rivières.
- - On s'est mis la tête
dadans le sable il y a quelques
anannées en se disant :
"I"Il commence à y avoir
unun problème, mais je ne veux s
lele voir. Je vais attendre d'êe
vrvraiment rendu au problème
popour le régler."
- - En 2018, le MTQ a annoncé
lele remplacement de 7 suspentes
popour les tester.
- - On n'est pas à remplacer
leles 160 suspentes. Et c'est ps
dedes travaux qu'on pourrait
jujuger urgents.
- - Pourtant, des échanges de
cocourriels obtenus par "Enquêt"
nonous apprennent que depuis
202016, des ingénieurs du MTQ
mamartèlent qu'il faut planifier
lele remplacement de toutes
leles suspentes pour éviter
leles travaux d'urgence.
OnOn venait de remplacer les dex
prpremières suspentes sur le pot
PiPierre-Laporte. L'une d'elles
avavait perdu près de 40 %
dede sa résistance d'origine.
- - Ah, ça, je suis pas au court
dede...
- - Mais vous étiez dans
leles échanges de courriels,
M.M. Mercier.
- - Il n'y a pas de sonnette
d'd'alarme qui ont été...
- - Ah non?
- - Non.
- - Avec le temps, les suspentes
onont continué de se dégrader,
tetellement qu'on a dû procéder
àà des remplacements d'urgence
l'l'automne dernier. Pendant
dedes semaines, la voie de droie
a a été interdite aux camions
lolourds dans les deux directio,
popour éviter de surcharger
leles câbles endommagés.
- - Au besoin, si on a à remplar
dedes suspentes, on pourra
lele faire. Il y a des contrats
ququi sont en cours, en cours de
sisignature. Il y a des commands
auaussi qui sont lancées.
ToTout ça se fait, évidemment,
popour assurer la sécurité
dudu public, assurer la pérennié
dede l'ouvrage.
- - Notre lanceur d'alerte estie
ququ'il faudrait avoir changé
totoutes les suspentes du pont
PiPierre-Laporte d'ici quatre
ouou cinq ans maximum.
C'C'est quoi votre stratégie,
c'c'est quoi le plan
dede remplacement complet?
- - Moi, je ne développe pas
dede plan de remplacement.
JeJe vais faire, en fin de comp,
seselon les recommandations
dedes experts à l'interne
auau ministère et des experts
àà l'externe.
- - Le ministère des Transports
prprévoit faire le remplacement
cocomplet des suspentes
susur un horizon de 5 à 15 ans,
mmême si dans leur récent
rarapport, les ingénieurs écrivt
quque "la rapidité avec laquelle
leles dommages progresseront
esest quasi impossible à estime.
LaLa gestion du risque
dede rupture de suspentes
n'n'est pas acceptable
susur une longue période."
DeDe quoi on a besoin de plus
popour aller de l'avant avec
unun plan de remplacement compl?
- - On veut savoir la durée
dede vie de la suspente. On veut
coconnaître par laquelle suspene
onon commence, par quelle suspee
onon va commencer, par quelle
sususpente on doit terminer.
CoCombien de temps on a?
- - Notre source aurait pu
sese tourner vers l'Ordre
dedes ingénieurs ou se prévaloir
dede la Loi protégeant
leles lanceurs d'alerte.
MaMais il doute de l'efficacité
etet de la confidentialité
dede ces processus.
- - J'ose espérer que juste
enen voyant ce qui va sortir
dadans le reportage,
lele gouvernement va réagir,
pupuis qu'il va dire : "Mettons
lele pied sur l'accélérateur."
- - Ici Marie-Pier Bouchard,
Radio-Canada, à Québec,
pour l'émission "Enquête